your Smurfs Lily yes okay your voice is
similar to your speaking voice is that
what you intended when you first got the
part or did you think you were gonna go
in there and do a different voice I
actually have never really gotten to do
anything animated that's been my own
voice so for me I was kind of expecting
I went in there and I was doing Smurf
Lily in a much higher register playing
her a lot younger and they were like no
you know we'd rather just have it in
your own voice and I was like oh that's
new okay right so it was kind of
exciting I just got to do it in my
regular voice I'm so used to just doing
weird voices I would oh you do weird
voices yeah what kind of weird voices
you do well I make this baby voice that
really freaks out my friends and my
boyfriend all the time and like it's
kind of fun for me to make them super
uncomfortable I'll just make Boyce makes
your boyfriend uncomfortable yeah okay
now I'm just a little baby I'm just a
little baby girl like oh my god that
would just yes I could see why that
would upset
that would be traumatic that's it so
please don't bless that out too often
that's a really good voice though it's
interesting so I know that if I went in
an audition for The Smurfs and started
to deal with voice and they were like no
Conan it's okay you can use your own
voice I'd be really insulted I'd feel
like oh wait a minute my voice yeah but
I can see that working out yeah
you